definite integral's throw that area
aren't they right well they tend to be
or about accumulated changes the thing
about them is when they've got
boundaries right there are some
different rules with some special rules
that apply them and don't apply it to
indefinite which I'll give you an
example you know that if you integrate a
function right and we usually think you
know you go from A to B right and we
tend to think of these lower and upper
bounds as being smaller and bigger
I guess it's why we call them lower it
off our right you know you go from 0 to
1 or PI to 2 pi that's the kind of idea
that makes sense right so you think if
you integrate something that's what
gives you the area okay
however we also know that you can switch
them around cut you there's nothing
stopping you mathematically from just
doing it the other way around
okay what effect does that have when you
evaluate it you could give it a go quit
you you can actually evaluate it if we
thought the vo if we call about F and so
it's integral will be f prime okay you
end up with something like this and then
you have to evaluate it if you swap the
order right so this is going to be F of
a minus F of B isn't it the other way
around and so this here is backwards to
what we used to it's backwards right but
therefore I can go back I can go back
and say well I could express this as the
definite integral that I started with
it's just that there's a minus sign out
the front and the order is what you'd
normally expect right so you have little
things like that other things like the
fact that you know from this step to
this step right can you see it didn't
matter that I had next year it didn't
matter what the variable was I could
have called this T and I would still
have stuck a and being and the T would
have vanished right and so that's why we
given a variable it's not just called
the variable integration has another
name yes minute before when you first
did integration
to the deep it's a dummy variable that's
right these guys if it's a definite
integral right they're just there as
kind of a um they're just keeping the
seat warm
really okay when you're doing your
calculation they're gonna go you're
going to get rid of them
they're just they're just as a
placeholder so you can put something
there and say that's what I'm going to
put numbers into okay so therefore I
could just as easily say for instance an
integral like this I'll write a normal
one if it's with respect to X it could
just as easily be with respect to say I
don't know theta or with respect to T or
with respect to any variable you like
because the variables going to go in the
end okay so these kinds of things these
are the two main examples of things that
only apply to definite integrals
obviously it doesn't make sense to say
any of these things are indefinite
integrals because it's all about the
boundaries right and how they interplay
with the whole integration process okay
so you can use things like this actually
that that's just to unit right but you
can use it to get other results I'll
give you an example we'll look at it
visually and then we'll prove it
algebraically okay here we go
the danger is so much in light extension
to in general right is that it soldiers
letters except that I 0 right and so
it's like what am I even doing be
careful right let's think of an example
and see how this plays out okay let's
think of something nice and easy to
integrate something like say on the EDX
it's 2d DX this is an example of this
okay because once you put in an actual
function we can draw it and we can see
it right so if I imagine that that's
what I'm considering is f right then I'm
going to consider this
yes okay now here's my example true all
this myth me what does this look like
okay this is an area is an area and it's
symmetrical about the y-axis isn't it
right so what a boundaries are
symmetrical I mean so if I put minus a
up for instance right is gonna say this
it's on this side so there you go I'm
working out an area like that right now
this stay but apparently is saying this
is equal to two other areas these two
areas can by their powers could by and
turn into this area okay what do they
look like right let's think about the
first one
not a of the same function okay where's
it'll play there's the same function
there's the origin in this so I'm only
considering this part that's not to aim
okay what's this one part look like this
is a different function isn't it has a
different it's been flipped horizontally
hasn't it right so I want to add
together this function but again I'm
going to same Valerie's not to a right
note hey can you see what happened can
you see what's wrong
can you see what this transformation
means right you can consider this whole
part or you can break it into two pieces
down the middle just consider this part
as usual that's exactly the same but
then think about this part and just turn
it backwards
and you'll get the same area these two
combined in your butt okay so being that
we can see it how do you prove it
algebraically hmm would anyone like to
suggest anything what could we do apart
from
I could do a substitution couldn't I I
want some of this but I think you can
remember it someone who rubbed off what
would be a good thing
substitute in I'll introduce something
let you what should I let it equal to
remember this is what I'm working with
here right so you've got X's here or
you've got negative X there so that
makes it a good candidate right so let
that equal that now when you do any
substitution right you kind of just
substitute the variable what other
pieces do you need when you've got
integration what else you have to do
you'll need the derivative point sure
you'll need the duty because I've got to
change the variable of integration if
I'm going to change the variable right
so do you on DX of course is just
negative 1 you can't just change those
to go this is a definite integral so
what else must not change I have to
change the boundaries don't sir ok I've
got two batteries I've got x equals zero
and x equals a over here okay what does
each one equal for you I mean
if x equals zero then you deserve a
problem if x equals a equals negative
eight
all right I kind of cheated a little bit
I said there are two boundaries I was
only looking at this integral over here
okay I've got another one donate there's
another boundary I haven't accounted for
namely negative a this one over here so
now I have a choice
as with all kinds of results that you
need to prove you can start from the
left right and then work with it to get
to the right or start with right and go
to the left which one would you like to
do any takers
right other hands up for a left hands up
and left
yeah one for the left okay that's fine
heads up go to for the left two and a
half card heads up for Ryan more people
fret why because oh yeah cuz blah blah
why no really I most of you did say
right why you think it's easier to
simplify go from something which has
more terms to something which has less
that's probably true you will see in a
second we can do it from either side and
it is fine and you need to get used to
doing it from you know taking something
which is simple and into and breaking it
apart that's something which is crucial
to understanding these but fine we'll go
democratically let's do it from the
right hand side okay so let's try this
okay that's why I started with
what's your first suggestion what should
I do with this to start working with it
I should split it shouldn't I because
this substitution u equals negative acts
right it's only really going to help you
work with this guy right if you don't
want it clouded with this and this this
part here already looks very much like
this right so you don't walk around with
it let's just leave him be over on this
side you've got this also from not today
okay so now at this point you've got
this ready to do the substitution let's
do all in one hit okay this guy's still
at the front and he always will be until
we combine them at the end zero and a I
gotta turn to zero and negative a right
that right yep okay what am I gonna have
in here I replaced negative X with you
I'm gonna replace this DX with ones that
go with a negative to you right so
there's my negative one do you so far so
good there's a couple things to notice
here though both of the things that I
drew your attention to before let me put
this guy out in front first I should do
this in two steps firstly it's negative
we can get rid of negative how should I
get rid of it it's a definite integral
right I will get rid of this negative by
turning the boundaries backwards right
and that kind of makes sense this is
going from zero to negative a that's
right to left which is not the normal
way we think right so I'm gonna resolve
that negative by saying this is now from
negative a to zero is that okay go into
that ah but now you see you know this X
this you they're going to disappear in a
minute right once I actually evaluate
this thing so it doesn't matter what
letters they are I can choose any
variable my life I'll just put instead
of this you put X back here
please notice it's not that u equals x
it doesn't right what it means is that
at this point it doesn't matter what the
variable is it could be you or X or tea
or theater or anything I like anything I
haven't even introduced because the same
person is going to govern it and the
same variables going to disappear when I
put the batteries in
okay now you can see it country right
you've got the same function being
integrated right you've got these two
sets of boundaries but they interlock at
zero and that's why you get to the left
hand side I suppose I'll run out of
space but you can see what's going on
kind of neat okay so are there steps
what do I go through I did this which is
kind of unnecessary but just so I could
see what was going on know what I was
doing right that's always nice when you
visualize it then you turn to the
algebra okay there's always going to be
some kind of substitution involved so
just like a normal substitution you work
out how to change that you choose a
suitable substitution you're gonna have
changed variable and then you take care
of the boundary the rest of it just
plays out after you stop everything you